nos dicen que un rectángulo tiene una
altura de 5 y un ancho de 3 x al
cuadrado menos x2 calcula el área de
todo el rectángulo la expresión debe ser
extendida pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta muy bien vamos
a resolverlo juntos lo que este diagrama
muestra es exactamente un rectángulo
indicativo cuya altura es de 5 y su
ancho es de 3 x cuadrada menos x + 2 y
lo que esto nos muestra es que el área
de todo el rectángulo puede
descomponerse en tres áreas más pequeñas
tenemos esta área azul de aquí cuyo
ancho es 3 x cuadrada y su altura es de
5 metros a que es igual esta área pues
es el alto por el ancho 5 x 3 x cuadrada
que es igual a 15 x cuadrada luego
tenemos esta otra área que de nuevo es
la altura por el ancho que es igual a 5
x menos x y quizás se pregunten cómo es
posible que tengamos un área de menos x
bueno pues nosotros no sabemos a qué es
igual x todo esto es un poco abstracto
pero podemos imaginar que x es un valor
negativo por lo que esto sería un ancho
positivo y otra cosa que quizá piensen
es hoy en esta área magenta parece ser
más grande que el área azul de acá como
sabemos eso la verdad es que no lo
sabemos
solo nos muestran esto como indicativo
pero quizá tengan la misma área que esta
otra o una puede ser más grande que la
otra pero esto sólo nos muestra que no
necesariamente son iguales es algo muy
abstracto no está dibujado a escala
porque no sabemos a qué es igual x muy
bien esta última área es igual a la
altura que es 5 por el ancho que es 2
por lo que esta área es igual a 10 lo
que acabamos de ver es que el área de
todo el rectángulo va a ser igual a la
suma de estas áreas que es igual a 15 x
cuadrada menos 5 x más 10
sé que quizá algunos de ustedes piensen
que si sabemos que la altura de 5 y que
el ancho es este valor por qué no
multiplicar este 5 por todo el ancho 3x
cuadrada menos x + 2 aquí naturalmente
distribuimos el 5 y es esencialmente lo
que hicimos aquí los modelos de área que
quizá vieron en la escuela primaria son
para comprender la propiedad
distributiva si distribuimos el 5
tenemos 15 x cuadrada menos 5 x + 10 la
misma idea hagamos otro ejemplo aquí
tenemos otro rectángulo y nos dicen un
rectángulo tiene una altura de 2 x que
vemos aquí y un ancho de 3 x 4 que
también vemos acá calcula el área de
todo el rectángulo la expresión debe ser
extendida es la misma idea pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo primero por
su cuenta muy bien podemos ver que la
altura es 2 x el total del ancho es 3 x
4 pero podemos ver con claridad que el
área de todo el rectángulo puede
descomponerse en esta sección azul y en
él
la sección magenta el área de la sección
azul es 3x x 2x que es igual a 6 x
cuadrada y el área de la sección magenta
es igual a ancho por alto que es 4 por 2
x lo que es igual a 8 x por lo que el
área de todo esto es igual a la suma de
estas dos áreas es 6x cuadrada más 8x y
terminamos nuevamente podríamos haber
pensado en esto como la multiplicación
del alto por el ancho multiplicar 2x por
el ancho que es 3 x 4 y después
distribuimos el 2x 2x por 3x es 6x
cuadrada + 2x por 4 es igual a 8 x es la
misma idea tenemos que asegurarnos que
entendemos que una vez que distribuimos
el 2x en este 3x y este 4 podemos
conceptualizarlo como encontrar las
áreas de cada una de estas subsecciones
del rectángulo